lots of people I think struggle with
building a network because they think
about it as people knowing people how
many people do I know how many followers
have I got how many connections have I
got on LinkedIn that is like the sign of
a good Network and that's not that
meaningful that doesn't mean you've got
a good Network you might be connected to
a lot of people but it doesn't mean
you've got a good Community around your
career a good Community around your
career is one that is active and
effective and so we think about it as
people helping people because if I'm
helping you that's active here's some
help it's an active thing and you've
been helped it is effective so when we
think about people helping people as the
basis for this it starts to get a lot
better and there's two big benefits of
it as well the first is people like
helping people like it's a human traits
like you get to help us high it's like
proven that I if I help you it makes me
feel good and so when people feel
awkward about building relationships
starting with how you can help and what
you've got to give it just feels nicer
foreign